DJ Dan thank you so much for joining us
thanks for having me yeah of course all
right we got a lot to talk about so
let's jump into it okay I mean how are
you feeling coming out of the house and
being in jury like does it feel real
the whole thing was very surreal in that
house you don't really have much time to
think to yourself so now that I'm out of
the house I'm kind of reflecting and
taking it all in and I'm very happy that
I made it to the jury house
um I feel like I accomplished
accomplished a lot there so yes I'm very
happy I'm here and I'm just reflecting
and taking it easy because it's very
taxing on the brain in there right all
right well as you know it was unanimous
vote uh what do you think that says
about the current dynamic in the house
right now
um I mean I think everyone wants to be
on the same page if there were a couple
people that voted to keep me that might
have put a Target on their backs and a
couple people before I left you know
they asked me if I wanted a vote almost
like a Pity vote and I was like no no I
want you to vote to keep yourself in the
best position so no hard feelings I
totally get it I totally understand
where everyone's coming from right okay
well I mean you campaigned pretty hard
this week Dan and I mean what was your
strategy going into different
conversations like were you surprised by
where any of those votes landed no I was
almost positive I was going home this
week I was trying to throw anything at
the wall and saw if it stuck my main
part of my campaign was telling people
that I do have a big Target on my back
so if I stay in the house there's a
little less of a Target on you that was
the main push of my campaign and then
with Koozie Anika and Daniel I tried to
tell them that I'm willing to join their
side and get tie out of the game it
might have been a lie at some points but
I was gonna say anything I could to keep
me in that house all right all right
okay so I mean what part of your
campaign strategy do you think worked
and what part didn't work
I think me telling people that I am a
Target so keeping keep keeping me in the
house sorry is good for them I think a
lot of people took that into
consideration
um I think just being against CC on the
Block is a tough position for me to be
in because I've shown that I can win
challenges
um and the people closest to me are
going to keep CeCe as well so I think I
was just in a tough spot all right okay
well we got to talk about the whodunit
week because it created like a ton of
paranoia in there I mean there were
house guests that you know also got
interrogated you know who do you believe
and you know I can't tell you yes or no
just so you know but who do you believe
in the end was the HOH and the POV
winners
I genuinely believe that Santina was the
HOH
um I was trying to read her her like
facial expressions during all of the
ceremonies
um and I was kind of like mad dogging
her a little bit as I'm sitting on the
Block as well as some other people and
just trying to read it
um and there was something she said to
Renee right after the Nom ceremony she
said shoot your shot turn it to Renee
um When Ty and I got put on the Block
and Santina claimed at that time that Ty
was her number one so it doesn't make
sense for her to congratulate Renee for
putting tie on the Block it just didn't
make sense
um so I really believe she was the HOH
the POV
man I don't know I think it could be
hope but I think it could be Thai Tai is
really smart and very calculated in
everything he does so I think he could
have had a bigger plan by not telling
anyone that he is a POV than taking
himself off the block
interesting all right okay I'm getting
into the mind of DJ Dan all right okay
so why do you think they made the
decision that they did
the HOH I believe
um because Ty and myself were closely
aligned with Zach the week he left I
think it just put a big Target on both
of our backs we've both shown that we
can compete in the physical competition
so that's another Target on our backs
and because you get no blood on your
hands and no one knows who done it I
think it was a perfect opportunity for
for whoever it was to put the both of us
up all right okay and so why do you
believe you're the one sitting in jury
right now DJ Dan I think
early on in the game I felt I needed to
show my hand that I am good at physical
competitions because I was put on the
Block week one I felt like I needed to
fight for my life in the game so in that
moment people started to realize oh Dan
can kind of compete in this stuff and I
think before that people didn't realize
that so from that moment going forward
um I was looked at as a physical threat
and I think that uh was to my detriment
okay all right well I gotta talk about
some of the drama in this house because
over the past few weeks there's been a
ton of drama a ton of bickering I want
to know who do you think in that house
is stirring the pot oh I mean before
Zach left 100 no doubt in my mind it was
Zach he was stirring the bot so much I
think right now though it's Ty Ty is
following at Zach's footsteps and I
think Ty likes to stir the pot very much
and like I said he's very calculated in
the things he does so it's definitely
Thai right now interesting okay and who
in your opinion butts heads the most in
that house ooh
[Music]
It's gotta be Thai and somewhat to be
honest I think Kai and Santina right now
are on Rocky Waters even though they
were closed at some point so they did
butt heads kind of me in there a little
bit the week I left
um so I'm excited to watch back and see
what happened you know this past week
between them
for sure okay well we saw you play this
game you know as an HOH and as a nominee
I want to know what do you think is the
high point of your bb can game and what
was your high point in the beauty can
house I think it definitely has to be
winning that HOH
um that was such an amazing feeling and
the fact that I was on the Block just
hours before winning it just made it all
the sweeter especially because I just
lost the POV comp to tie a few days
prior
um I felt like I was at the bottom and I
went to the top and it was the best
feeling in the world I can't even
describe
sounds familiar okay so uh do you have
any regrets from your game in the beauty
can house I like to try to live my life
with a no regrets attitude but if there
was something that I could change I
probably wouldn't have been so trustful
in Zach early on the game before I was
really sure of how much he trusted me or
wanted to work with me and I think it
kind of bit me in the butt a little bit
you know looking back so I don't know if
I'd call it a regret but that's one
thing that I would do definitely uh if I
could okay now you worked with a few
people a few different people
strategically through the game who do
you feel you were the closest to in the
house uh definitely nene nene is my
bestie in the house she made my time
there super enjoyable I feel like I can
trust her with anything I feel like
we're really similar people so she was
definitely the person I was closest with
and I'm really happy that we were in the
house together
cool all right and what do you think
that Nene needs to do in order to get
further in the game
I think Nene needs to really lock in uh
an alliance she's closely aligned with
Cece and Renee
um I feel like maybe she should try and
explore other options silently along
with them
um just to have more numbers on her side
in the case that she needs it okay all
right well I gotta know DJ Dan what is
your biggest personal takeaway from your
game in the BB can house
wow I mean
I to be honest I think I'm just so
grateful to be a part of that experience
it was a once in a lifetime opportunity
and there are so many moments that I'm
gonna cherish and remember for the rest
of my life and just the experience
overall I am so grateful for and I loved
being a part of it wonderful all right
well you may be out of the house but you
aren't out of the game and I want to
know what are you looking for in a
player to make them worthy of your vote
in the end
I'm definitely going to be looking for
people who are able to adapt
um I want someone to be able to you know
go with the flow and adapt week by week
when the dynamic changes in the house
and someone who's able to last the last
few weeks and make it to the end while
having to change up their game is
something I'm going to be looking for
for sure interesting okay so would you
say you're more social or strategic
um I love a social game that was
definitely where I lacked and so someone
who's really good socially
um is impressive to me and that's
something I'm going to be looking for as
well all right cool well last but not
least I gotta know who do you think is
going to take you know the big win the
Big W for bbcan 11. there's a couple
people that I've been you know tossing
back and forth in my mind of who I think
might win and right now I'm rocking with
Koozie I think Koozie is very good
socially she can win competitions and
she has a good foundation inner Alliance
so I think Koozie could go all the way
all right cool well thank you again Dan
and I mean welcome to the BB can fam
because I mean we're a little crazy but
you know it's a fun time and so many
people have dreamed about being in the
position that you are in so you you did
it so congrats to you thank you so much
I appreciate it you're welcome take care
all right have a good one thanks